I'm here with Ross.
Hi (giggles).
And Michelle Park, who is a lifestyle expert,
and going to teach us something that's gonna make us
look at our toaster differently for the rest of our lives.
Michelle, we're ready.
Take us to the next level.
Oh my God, look at you guys with your toasters.
That's so cute.
We are so excited.
So, I'm gonna make you a toaster quesadilla.
So, it's super-simple.
Grab any kind of, like, burrito or tortilla.
We have stuff, here.
Ross and I are in-synch.
We've got our trays all ready to go.
Look at you guys.
All right, so you're gonna grab your tortilla.
You're gonna put one layer of your preferred meat.
I'm gonna put turkey on mine.
Ditto.
Like, imagine you're gonna make a dumpling, okay?
So, you want the edges to be free,
so just stick it in the middle.
Okay.
Yep, it's in the middle.
One slice of your preferred cheese
will also go right on top of that, just like that, okay?
I'm gonna go with an American cheddary-type.
I could make some sort of cheesy joke right here,
but I won't.
(all laughing)
All right, so now we're gonna get some guacamole on there.
I think of guacamole as the glue.
So, it's gonna, kind of like, hold everything together.
Oh yeah, it's the glue on my thighs, Michelle.
I'll tell you that much.
Girl, same here.
Guacamole team.
I'm just like, spread it, who cares?
That's what I'm guaccing about.
Yeah.
Guac and roll (laughs).
(laughing) Michelle, bravo.
She's our kind of gal.
You can hang.
All right, so now you're gonna take your shredded cheese
and put this on top.
Fold the top up like this, and then fold the sides in.
So, you want everything in this, kind of like, envelope.
I kind of got messy with my guacamole,
so I'll just keep going, look.
I think I'm kind of doing, like, surprisingly well.
I'm shocked.
You know what a hazard I am in the kitchen.
I'm proud of you, Drew.
(Drew laughs)
Mine's a mess.
So, do I pop this in the toaster now?
Yeah, so stick your little envelope into the toaster.
I'm gonna turn my toaster on.
I kind of like, hold onto it on its way down, okay?
Or you could just go hard-core like that.
Oh yeah, I'm just like (grunts).
(crew laughing)
And then, I let it toast for 20 to 30 seconds,
and when it pops up, we'll slice it open
and you'll see all the melty cheesy goodness.
I will say, wooden tongs because obviously
you don't wanna stick metal tongs in the toaster
and yow, electrocute yourself.
My kid's grandmother, Coco, Grammy,
she always has toast tongs and they're amazing,
and they're a game changer because I am that type who, like,
sticks my finger down in there and I always regret it.
That's a no-go.
That's a good hack, I like that.
I need to get me some toast tongs.
I'm gonna, whoa.
Whoa.
Ouch, it's hot and delicious.
(crew applauding)
Oh my gosh, I did it, Michelle.
Thanks to you.
It looks good.
I like it when, untoasted.
(Drew and Michelle laughing)
I'm gonna taste it.
Yeah, you try it.
There's one here made for me.
Mm.
This would be like my favorite after, I'm sorry.
(Drew and Michelle laughing)
I don't know where you're going with that,
which means you're getting some, fantastic.
Michelle, thank you so much.
These are delicious, by the way.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
What she said (laughs).
Thank you so much, Michelle,
for coming here and brightening up our lives,
and teaching us such a cool toaster hack.
We're very grateful.
Thank you.
I have guacamole on my nose now,
worry about the mess over here.
Nose-amole.
Now, we're out of time and we hate that because we never
want this show to end.
So, we wanna leave you with a little something
that you can take with you.
A little thing we like to call The Doggy Bag.
(music sparkles)
(dog barks)
(crew applauding)
And today, it's an old trick that people
have been doing for ages.
And I love doing it.
It's just I lack consistency and discipline.
But, lemon water.
When I do it, my whole life changes.
It's incredibly good for your organs,
great for digestion, completely cleans you out.
Oh really?
Trust.
Somebody get me a lemon.
Thank you so much for being here
and we'll see you guys tomorrow.
(upbeat music)